tenet is a complicated movie with many
answers hiding behind complex layers of
time travel logic
but even still not everything gets
wrapped up so nicely
here are the biggest questions tennis
left hanging and what these apparent
gaps in the story
might mean the climax of tenant is a
complicated combat operation
during which two teams move in on the
city where andre sater grew up he's
hidden the algorithm there
with intentions to destroy it and the
hero's mission is to secure the
algorithm
in a temporal pincer move which turns
out to be precisely as cool as it sounds
like it would be
robert pattinson's neil is a part of the
attack team that is inverted for the
operation
while the protagonist is not handling
his part of the assault while moving
forward through time
with the military commander ives but as
the operation begins to fall apart due
to counter measures prevented by the
enemy
neo breaks off from the team to work on
his own sprinting toward an enemy
turnstile sneaking inside and inverting
himself in time
the operation successfully ends with him
using a humvee to hold the protagonist
ives and the algorithm out of the pit in
the closed city before the coveted
device can be buried by the explosion
sata had arranged to keep the algorithm
out of everyone's hands
we see that neil is above ground
throughout the entire scenario but the
red string and washer he keeps attached
to his kit
reveals the movie's final gut punch of
an emotional twist turns out
neil is also underground masked in a
balaclava
and seemingly dead on the floor when the
protagonist is trying to get through a
locked door just when things start to
appear hopeless this other neil's body
obviously inverted in time
springs to life and saves the
protagonist opening the door for him at
exactly the right time before sprinting
away backwards but if neil has to get
the humvee up above too
that means that there are two kneels
operating simultaneously
both having arrived from different
timelines when did that happen
and how we can certainly respect neil's
dedication to the course
and his buddy the protagonist it's clear
that neil's ultimate fate
after the last moment the audience sees
him is to die for the sake of the
mission
still a little bit of a hint as to how
neil swings that after getting on the
helicarrier
would provide a little bit of closure
which neither the protagonist
nor the audience gets to have one huge
and answered question about satan's
nihilistic plan is
who in the future was andre sater
getting his intel and technology from
it could be the protagonist in the
future we don't see it's the first
natural assumption to make
since he's directly or indirectly
responsible for a whole lot of what
happens in the movie story
but if he was responsible for stringing
satya along as a very very long khan
it seems like an awfully risky scheme to
secure the algorithm
it also runs contrary to his established
morals of empathy and having an interest
in keeping the algorithm in separate
pieces
not together the movie still needs the
antagonist so it's probably not the
protagonist
you know what we're saying oh fanciful
word play
indeed the armstealer priya is a heck of
a conundrum her character is extremely
important
as she establishes a contrasting
interest in pursuing the algorithm
she is ultimately an antagonist but she
thinks she is operating in conjunction
with tennis ideals
at the end of the movie the protagonist
shares with her is revelation
that she and everyone else is somehow
working for a future version of him
if that's the case and her purpose as a
temporal chess piece
appears to be as a vector of
deliberately incorrect information
maybe tenet's true purpose is to find
people who would gather the algorithm
rather than keep it separated how could
priya end up being wrong about that
ideal when she spends most of the movie
in a place of relative status and
knowledge was that the effort of people
acting against the protagonist or the
downstream effect of something the
future protagonist created himself
how many people like her are out there
who are aware of tenet but not allied
with the protagonist
none of these questions can be answered
without knowing where priya came from
and how she came to learn about tenet
the husband she uses as an avatar for
her business as an arms dealer
really doesn't know what 10 it is since
the protagonist is very careful to only
use the hand sign
and word in a clandestine way and priya
talks to him about it with her husband
well out of earshot
basically what's her story and how does
she end up in the unique position that
she's in
the first act of the movie involves a
protagonist being recruited for tenet by
his boss
victor victor describes a kiev operation
that resulted in the protagonist's
attempted death by cyanide pill as
a test which he passes but beyond that
victor doesn't know a lot about what
tenet actually is
and seems to conceive of the
protagonist's objective as a shadow op
to
learn more about tenets on behalf of the
cia how convicted sets the protagonist
for entry to a collective that he
doesn't understand
welcome to the afterlife when the
protagonist calls him in mumbai he
refers to him as though he's no longer
beholden to the cia
and the protagonist treats the
relationship the same way asking for a
favor from
old allies how did victor learn about
any of this if he simultaneously is
aware of tenet and yet is requesting
someone else to go out on missions to
learn more
and with an authority separate from the
cia at that because of the ending
we can appreciate well enough that the
future protagonist is essentially
recruiting himself through a proxy
and that's really all that matters for
the story but what was victor's place in
that long
long chain of events according to the
general conceit of inversion
anti-tenants actually works as revealed
by the ending
clearing the protagonist in on tenet is
an end result that we don't see the
process of
all we get to know about victor's
involvement is through the most
important action
telling the protagonists that he
qualifies to learn about tennet because
of his sense of self sacrifice
basically we don't quite understand
where he truly came from and he would
have had to have some kind of journey
himself to learn about tenet at all
that we never see the grandfather
paradox has kicked around in
philosophical discussion multiple
times throughout tenet and at the end of
all things in its complex temporal
labyrinth
it's worth asking again did all of what
happened happen once they're all done
like overall it happened to some of them
sure but does it still exist in the
collective world
neil's ultimate answer to the
protagonist when he asks about the
paradox as a big fat
i don't know and that's probably the
thorough intent of the question
we can't know and we won't metaphysics
aside cat has a scar no matter what
satan ends up dead and the items
drifting back through time are still
doing so
exactly as instructed in the moment they
are seen in the movie these things must
occur for the ending to happen after all
it's heavily implied that the
protagonists and his allies will have to
continue performing missions like this
in their lives
relative past and present alike to
maintain this series of events as we see
them in tenets to keep them true for
themselves
it must continue happening constantly
less semester mean it does
indeed become unhappened or something
our brains hurt too it's okay didn't try
to understand it
[Music]
feel it a big weird looking stick that
represents math that's what the
algorithm is but it's fate is somewhat
murky when you stop to consider the
totality
of the situation 10 attends in a manner
that feels unambiguously happy
our heroes have won and space time has
been saved but that victory can only be
accomplished by successfully secreting
the pieces of the algorithm away like
harry potter horcruxes between the
protagonists
neil and dives who each got three parts
where exactly would that be
people who know of tenet are everywhere
and as far as we can tell at all points
in time too
and they aren't necessarily aligned with
the hero's beliefs that the pieces
should be kept apart
it's a tall order all on its own made
more complicated by knowing neil
eventually dies in a way we don't see in
the soviet city they just claimed the
algorithm from
did neil get a chance to hide all three
of his pieces before he goes back to put
himself
there or it's just placed there making
sure he's on the other side of that long
gate to save the protagonist at just the
right second meant to make up for a
mistake on his part
tenet as a protagonist intends to use it
is a very elaborate game of keep away
with the algorithm
it's heavily implied that the good
ending we see is something that has to
be actively maintained through time by
the protagonist and his allies
after all the algorithm's creator who
also was a big unanswered question
herself
originally hid the pieces and that
clearly didn't do any permanent good
the conflict of the day encapsulated in
satar's well-destroying death wish
is over but the greater conflict isn't
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you